pricing for the HTC vive the VR headset
in development at HTC and valve has been
revealed at the Mobile World Congress
and its eight hundred dollars or as I
originally put it when I read the news
this morning it's 800 king dollars
sitting two hundred dollars above the
price of the oculus rift which is
already a whopping 600 bucks the vibes
price has been dropping a bunch of
chores today the consumer edition will
arrive with the headset two wireless
controllers two base stations a link box
to connect it to your pc and a pair of
earbuds pre-orders go live at 7am on
febri 29 and the headset is due to
shipped in April as you probably already
guessed you will also need a pc rig
capable of running the device HTC v RVP
dan o'brien told gamespot sister sites
seen it there is nothing else that can
do what the vibe does he added it's more
compelling than buying things piecemeal
in reference to the fact that you also
get controllers as part of the eight
hundred dollar package five units will
ship with free copies of job simulator
and fantastic contraption and extra
games will be sold for the platform
through stains let me know what you
think of the price and if you'll pick
this one up in that comment section for
everything VR and all the news still
coming out of Mobile World Congress stay
tuned to gamespot
you